their new player seven and this is
definitely a new player I have not
played this account before I feel like I
have to say a count anymore offensive
player because of those that create
multiple accounts which is not cool
let's go c5 or c6 French or d5
Scandinavian or none of the above a lien
or Alec kind flip a coin on the
pronunciation maybe and you'll hear me
use both pronunciations Alec I'm a Ellie
K H I and II II five is the main move I
guess main line Alec I anyhow there's a
sequence of moves that can be played
here where there are Inbetweeners
richens ugh probably butchering that and
we're seeing it right now so no I will
not run away with my knight you will run
away with your knight maybe if you ran
away then I would occupy the center
something you take me I take deal in
between or variation we could call this
alkynes defense the in-betweener
variation that's not really a thing but
I make some words up as I go along if
you've been on any of the streams you'll
know I'm I make up a lot of stuff I
think it's just easier to say
in-betweener then suck so I don't take
right away I make sure I once again in
between 'red that's how many
Inbetweeners in a row mmm that's like
three and between errs in a row and I
once again don't react to that throw in
another in-betweener give a check and
finally chop that pod up so after the
smoke has cleared what in the world is
going on
well we are in endgame land for sure and
the Queen's are on the sidelines
watching both of us play so do I want to
Castle queenside or Kings side is the
one thing I'm thinking of here that's
the first question that pops in my mind
and now I think if I'm gonna Castle
queenside I will want to follow up with
knight c6 Bishop d7 and then boom how's
that however is this gonna be a problem
if I Castle queenside is f7 gonna be a
target might be boom I don't know let's
give it a shot
if the bishop plays here I could play e5
and kind of just slam the door in its
face okay I did anticipate that move
this is a convenient reply I'm pretty
sure maybe h6 is something of a
necessity is it to stop Knight g5 that
can be quite annoying maybe I don't want
to even Castle queenside that's another
thing I really want to cast the
queenside maybe maybe not
okay well I'm not having to worry about
Knight g5 now I think queenside castle
what might I have to worry about though
a knight maybe getting to h5 could be a
pain this is where I have an isolated
pun in identifying weak points weak
pawns will allow you to maybe start to
see weak squares did you follow that I
don't think I've ever phrased it like
that before but I think it came out
pretty good good thing
identifying weak pawns will allow you to
identify weak squares this is isolated
having this knight pivot on h5 might be
pretty good in the meantime queenside
castle if the knight threats to come
here I can always play h5
I think we're doing all right as black
right here - just Castle queenside which
is I guess a bit more you'll see the
queenside castle happen a bit more if
once castle the rook is already having
an influence on the position it's
working well it's doing something
constructive it is on and it is on not a
half-open Fouts on an open file and now
with that Knight move what is the big
plan here I think I just post up right
here in the centre that looks that looks
really good so I'm gonna do it trade
bishops I'm one step closer to just
doubling rooks and Wow
and I'm within a checking distance there
might be some annoying things I could be
doing there huh that's a bit of a pain
about polish well that's getting a
little bit weird Wow pop push here
I think that's all right no I think it's
bad if I do this Bishop here my Knights
unprotected let me do this yeah that was
almost a slip right there I wouldn't
have been good okay I do not want to
have doubled pawns like that double
isolated pawns no way no thanks
it's just tough white really doesn't
obtain like a great advantage or
anything but um I don't have anything
either um what's the plan well pressure
on this pawn stops my knife from moving
that seems pretty good all right it
looks silly but I want to be able to
move my knight okay now my knight might
want to play here or just right in the
center let's do this first f5 is
available I think that could turn out to
be a good home I might want to support
that night or I might want to secure
this Knights position by playing h5 I
anticipate playing e6 soon and I'm
having second thoughts about this h5
move because I think Knight coming here
is once again going to be a bit annoying
so let's do this I could definitely end
up in a pin here I could get out of it
with Knight f5 though I am defending the
bishop when I retreat like this I might
want to also consider b6 to make sure
the knight doesn't get here that could
be a bit annoying if this pawn moves I
have f3 available a minute three-two a
minute 35 this is a good game so far and
now what is the plan let's come here
if pawn push I get play to h4 and then
look at this f3 square
this is a really slow game really really
slow game a lot of maneuvering a lot of
making sure of what what am I trying to
do here am i trying to say I'm trying to
say I have to be real cautious about the
placement the potential placement of my
opponent's pieces this night was having
me do a lot of thinking with my pawn
pushes do I really want to preserve my
knight by playing h5 and allow Knight g5
when I play more calm defensive h6 move
to stop him from coming to my territory
and okay well I think pawn push here is
good maybe a rook lift might be good
yeah this might be good
rook here and then here or just looking
to maybe double after that I'm gonna try
that one seems very active it is
unprotected
there is no bishop move which would give
check ooh I missed that I better come
here pawn push pawn push might be played
pawn push pawn push might be playing
right oh oh no I'm on the night if the
pawn pushes there maybe I could consider
f5 okay and now what the knight has to
go somewhere else and with this f5 move
one of the reasons I went for it is
because of what its cementing this pawn
on f4 and maybe I could target it like
so if the rook came to pin I was gonna
play here I'm looking to just put
pressure on this ponceau and I'm winning
that pawn
I want my King in a better position
first though or not okay well I better
go with this this is a this is a drawn
position here
let's try and win it though King
position if I have anything it's maybe a
king position
I guess the knight could be playing
there let's stop that King position is
the only thing I have and my night and
is my night isn't a good spot I could
defend that and then come back oh I
almost missed that just come over here I
could defend this and then and then run
with my pond no oh I'm dropping that but
I could push you know quick at this
point go quick go quick don't allow for
stalemate just keep pushing keep pushing
keep pushing keep pushing
actually let's do this I don't want to
um I don't want to get into stalemate
situations so this player was I think
better than their rating in fact I know
they're much better than their rating
were they a sneaky player I think they
might have been a sneaky player anyhow
good game versus a new player Oh seven
let's flip that board and let's see what
went on here so in-betweener variation I
guess we could call it I had to be
really cautious about this Knights
decision to maybe get to h5 if f4 g3 was
played I had been I was going to be
ready to play h5 and I wonder what this
players real strength is because they're
not playing at the
they have their you're not fooling me so
this is this is a tight game and in this
final position right here I think it's
just turning out to be equal right here
right here there's there's no okay if
there's some advantage I guess it would
be to black just because of maybe King
position but that's about it maybe it
maybe it turns out to be just enough a
lot of calculations still needed in this
endgame tricky Knights tricky Knights
tricky Knights so yeah King and pawn in
game there's calculation needed of
course and you throw a knight on the
board for both sides and there's even
more calculation needed so this was a
good game a lot a lot of things to watch
out for a lot of precautionary moves and
I think a lot of patients needed for
both sides and white uh I did show that
okay